There are a lot of reasons why Stephen King's
It was ripe for revival on-screen in 2017.
It'd been 27 years since the last adaptation,
which is a fateful number in the story.
Clowns are still pretty damn scary.
And, well, the 1990 TV miniseries simply couldn't
capture the most terrifying elements of King's
bestseller under network restrictions and
a small-screen budget.
The outdated special effects in particular
have rendered certain portions of the original
It film laughable, instead of frightening.
Even so, there are certain scenes in the 1990
miniseries that still hold up — and are
actually even scarier than the new big-screen
adaptation.
The moving pictures
The 2017 version of It includes a memorably
terrifying sequence in which Pennywise comes
to life within a sinister slideshow, but the
1990 version of that moment is a bit eerier
in some respects.
Bill Denbrough is alone and still completely
grief-stricken about his brother Georgie's
funeral when he first comes into contact with
It.
He skims through a book of photos, when all
of a sudden Georgie's most recent picture
winks at him...and starts oozing blood.
What's worse is that Bill's parents are more
concerned about him not belonging in the room
than finding out what he saw — or more importantly,
what they can't see.
It's nightmarish enough not to be believed
or heard by your parents, but when they're
smearing invisible blood all over your murdered
brother's room it's even worse.
Pennywise's page-bouncing also comes into
play later on when the Losers look at Mike's
dad's photo album about Derry's many child-murder
sprees, and the town square's carnival comes
to life with a certain dancing clown at the
center.
If the slow burn of him coming into closer,
full-color view isn't scary enough, the fact
that he then reaches through the page to grab
at the Losers should keep you up at night.
Ben's father
The new version of It makes very little of
Ben Hanscom's background, but the miniseries
introduces a gnawing element of the story
that still works as a hair-raiser.
Early on, Ben is seen traipsing through the
Barrens alone and sees his long-lost father
in full military dress, standing in the swamp
and beckoning him into the sewer.
The 2017 movie offers its own share of Pennywise's
dread-inducing impressions.
But the idea that Ben's dead dad would slowly
morph into the clown like that is a kind of
creepy cruelty that's hard to forget.
Beverly's bathroom
The 2017 movie does a good job of depicting
Beverly Marsh's infamous bloody bathroom — her
physical maturation is stoking fear in Beverly
and others in her life.
But there's still something extraordinarily
unsettling about the 1990 version.
It's slower, there are children's voices crying
out to Beverly …
"I'm Matthew O'Connor.
We're all the dead kids."
And once the balloon of blood explodes all
over the place, Mr. Marsh puts his hands right
into the gory mess, unable or unwilling to
see what his kid sees.
So, it's a test of her squeamishness and sanity.
Eddie's shower
There's no denying that Eddie Kaspbrak's first
encounter with It in the 2017 version is really
creepy.
But there's a certain emotional vulnerability
that's lost in translation from the first.
In the first version, Eddie is being pinballed
by the adults in his life — his mother has
told him not to shower at school, but his
gym teacher absolutely insists he does.
Everyone else has already cleaned up by the
time Coach wins the argument, which leaves
Eddie out to dry solo in the school showers
— just as they start to come to life.
Mid-rinse, all the nozzles start operating
themselves and turn every spout into a scalding
torture device meant to steer Eddie away from
safety just before Pennywise pays him a visit
through the drain.
If Psycho didn't make you think twice about
showering away from home, here's another scene
that'll creep into your memory at the worst
moment.
Going clear
The kids' final stand against Pennywise in
the new film is incredibly similar to what
goes down in the miniseries.
And both ignore the novel's very weird Ritual
of Chüd in favor of a more old-fashioned
fight with It, and make their pact to come
back together if and when It returns.
But despite all the faults to be found in
the camerawork, props, and visual effects,
the 1990 version is still highly effective,
thanks to some key fog machine work and the
attack on poor Stan.
While the Losers are trying to stay together,
Pennywise already sees the weakest links in
their chain and tries to make a meal out of
Stanley Uris.
It's a terrible preview of what's to come,
and the fact that Pennywise is able to break
their chain certainly undermines their sense
of strength in numbers.
"I am eternal child."
The meta element
One of the essential elements of the first
movie is how informative pop-culture was to
the Losers' fear.
For example, within days of the group seeing
I Was a Teenage Werewolf at the Paramount
theater, the group's most entertainment-oriented
member, Richie Tozier, is chased through the
school's basement by a werewolf in a varsity
jacket.
That scene speaks volumes about Stephen King's
story and influences, as it derives from so
many other scares while also informing new
nightmares all its own.
"They float, Georgie.
They float."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!